stranger things 3 is without a doubt the
big release for July but there's plenty
more to look forward to here's a look at
everything good coming to Netflix in
july 2019 starting with the Netflix
originals history buffs aren't the only
audience for Netflix is upcoming the
last Czar's the series will combine
documentary style information plugs with
dramatic reenactments to trace the
history of tsar nicholas ii russia's
last emperor let's put it this way if
your only knowledge of the Romanovs the
February Revolution and Rasputin comes
from watching anastasiya as a kid get
ready for a whole new world of insight
into the revolution that brought the
Romanov dynasty to its knees
tune in for the entire series when it
arrives on July 3rd there probably isn't
a single person watching this who needs
a recap of stranger things
Netflix's throwback horror fantasy
series took the streaming world by storm
in 2016 then up the insanity with season
2 in 2017 it's hard to believe that
nearly 2 years have passed since we last
saw 11 and her friends battled the
forces of the upside down but it looks
like the wait was more than worth it
stranger things three seas the kids a
little older and hopefully a little
wiser as their hometown of Hawkins
Indiana is once again threatened by
otherworldly beasts take a look when
stranger things 3 arrives on July 4th
don't let the subtitles turn you off to
cities of last things if you're a fan of
gritty psychological thrillers like
momento or jacob's ladder' you'll have a
good time watching this dystopian
Taiwanese film told in reverse
chronological order the story follows a
depressed
ex-cop whose life is on a downward
spiral beginning with one shocking act
city of last things then backtracks over
the three days leading up to his fateful
decision look for it to hit Netflix on
July 11th Anthony Mackie takes the lead
in point blank as a nurse on the hunt
for the criminals who kidnapped his
pregnant wife to bring the thugs to
justice he'll have to team up with the
suspect of a murder investigation played
by Frank Grillo and descend into the
criminal underworld
where are you going I'm gonna kill him
Oh
Point Blank is a remake of the 2011
French thriller of the same name and
Netflix couldn't have picked a better
source for their film the original
garnered a 91% approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes with critics praising the sharp
action and furious pace look for Point
Blank to land on Netflix on July 12th
how do you give audiences a fresh take
on the age-old Frankenstein story easy
you do whatever the hell Netflix is
doing with Frankenstein's monsters
monster Frankenstein not only is that a
tongue twister of a title it also looks
like a brain twister of a story stranger
things as David Harbour stars in this
short mockumentary as a man who's
digging into his father's past to
uncover secrets about an old
Frankenstein themed play what does it
all mean we'll have to wait until July
16th to find out when Frankenstein's
monsters monster Frankenstein shows up
on Netflix
secret obsession centers on a woman
named Jennifer played by the social
networks Brenda song who wakes up to a
head full of amnesia and a husband who
may be keeping dangerous secrets from
her Mike Vogel co-stars as Jennifer's
husband Russell Netflix says so far only
tease the upcoming film but all signs
point to a tense edge-of-your-seat
thriller take a look on July 18 if
you're one of the avid Watchers of La
de papel or money heist you're no doubt
pumped about the series's return
according to Deadline it's the streaming
services most popular non English
language series and if you've ever given
it a chance you know that it's worth the
hype even if you haven't tried it you
might still recognize it as the one with
all the people in masks and red
jumpsuits without giving too much away
the show basically involves an elaborate
heist on the Spanish Royal Mint
originally slated as a limited series in
Spain Netflix commissioned two-third
parts in early 2018 most likely due to
the overwhelming popularity of the
series if this is your first run-in with
money heist you still have plenty of
time to catch up before part three
arrives on July 19th we're not entirely
sure what to expect with this upcoming
Syfy series but hopefully another life
turns out just as good as it looks
Katee Sackhoff stars as an astronaut
who's leading the crew into space to
check out a mysterious alien artifact
another life comes from creator Aaron
Martin who also created Netflix's horror
series slasher another show we're
checking out for horror fans take a look
at another life when the first season
arrives on July 25th fans who have
followed oranges the new black for six
seasons are surely getting excited about
the upcoming series finale season seven
seas Piper out of prison and trying to
cope with her life in the outside world
but finding it tougher than she expected
much of the cast has come forward to
shed a light on their feelings about the
series's end with most conceding that
it's a bittersweet finale tune in for
the final season of orange is the new
black when it premieres on July 26th
Netflix is closing out the month with
the red sea diving resorts a political
action thriller starring Chris Evans as
the leader of a team working to get
Ethiopian refugees to safety according
to BBC the premise is based on a
real-life resorts in Sudan that was set
out by Mossad agents in the 80s it's an
intriguing story man we can't wait to
see what Chris Evans does with the role
look for it on July 31st that covers all
the best new Netflix originals for July
let's pivot now to check out the rest of
the films heading our way
Netflix is clearly focusing the month on
its original films and series band while
there's plenty to look forward to there
there aren't a lot of licensed genre
films to look forward to action is
taking a real hit with only four
editions in July all of which arrived on
the first fortunately they're all worth
watch even if it's a rewatch 1989's Road
house is showing up right beside 2001
swordfish 2010's the Book of Eli and
2005 offbeat fantasy adventure comedy
the Brothers Grimm
similarly there are only three new
additions in the thriller genre look for
2006 s mean dreams which marks Bill
Paxton's final film role mean dreams is
a dramatic thriller about a boy named
Jonas who sees his father a corrupt
police officer steal a satchel of drug
money
Jonas takes the money and leaves with
his girlfriend looking for a better life
but it isn't long before his own father
begins hunting him down
you can catch mean dreams on July 1st
along with everyone's favorite shaky
monster movie Cloverfield and scream 3
it's your turn to scream on the drama
front Netflix is adding some of the more
obscure earlier Martin Scorsese films
including 1973's Mean Streets 1974's
Alice doesn't live here anymore
and 1967's who's that knocking at my
door
all of those arrived in July first other
additions on the 1st of the month
include Oscar winners Rain Man and
Philadelphia with 2011 s the Iron Lady
coming on the 6th finally close out the
month with Quentin Tarantino's World War
2 opus inglorious basterds on the 22nd
notable comedy additions include both
Caddyshack films The Hangover
and the two Pink Panther reboot films if
you're into that kind of thing those all
show up on the first check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
Netflix shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]